Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
Yeah, go down 13. You're going to see this.
You're going to see the store on the right hand side.
You'll see liquor store on right hand side. You make a,
you're gonna make a left. That's bears. Actually this bears beets
and this, oh, it's called Bauer speech is your porter and lots of knots. Okay.
Okay. I'm going to go to, you don't want to go further.
So three years ago,
three or four years ago,
I taken the bus down to Delaware and I stayed in this crappy hotel and then woke
up super early, like 5:00 AM still dark out to hop in this camp.
You're going to see a horse. Oh, I'm, you have got me really excited.
Let me tell her.
Just started working at Radiolab. This was like my first, uh,
first time I'd been sent out to like to just go out and get tape.
You talked to anybody or they'll tell you,
anybody that lives on that beach would be glad to talk to you. Awesome.
Awesome.
And the whole reason why I was headed down to this beach was to record myself
communing with a horseshoe crab.
Have you ever held one Lexus? Have you ever, I've never had one in my hands.
I would love to hold one in my hand. Yeah. Robert, you sound very far away.
I know it's [inaudible] just to explain,
we sent Latif down to that beach
because a few weeks earlier. All right, everybody say something. Who Do? Hello.
Hello. Robert and I had sort of fallen into this rabbit hole. Hello? Uh,
we'd spoken with a guy named Alexis Madrigal. Yup.
Who is a staff writer at the Atlantic. How did you get onto Horseshoe Krebs?
Where did that start for you? Um, I, it was
late@nightandiwasreadingthroughthesitewhereallthesecrazypressreleasesarepublishedcalledeurekaalert.com.
And I happened to see this really tiny study which had the unpromising name sub
lethal behavior and physiological effects of the biomedical bleeding process on
the American horseshoe crab Limulus Pala FEMAs.
And I thought this is going to be my big story this year.
And then I went, um, and I did that thing that we do now, you know,
horseshoe crab and then Google images and uh,
they're on the screen. According to Alexis,
he saw these pictures of a bunch of horseshoe crabs kind of propped up on these
metal racks and they were all Kinda tied in place and they were all in a row and
they all had these thin little plastic tubes coming out of their shells,
all of them. And underneath them are what look like kind of a two liter
bottle and
there's blue blood in it,
blue
like baby blue blood. And,
and what was just so fascinating is the strange blood.
It turns out to be the least interesting part of the story. Like at some level,
like it's just the visual that draws you in because inside there strange the
horseshoe crabs have a kind of superpower.
It's one that has helped them survive hundreds of millions of years as the earth
has changed, as other species have come and gone.
And it hasn't just been saving their butts.
It's been saving ours for decades.
Nearly all of modern medicine would not be possible without this special little
thing in their blood. But
it might all be about to change.
Oh Wow. Oh No. Even over there. Yeah. Right. Yourselves in the puddle. Yep.
The love plateau. Yeah.
One thing that it does that is really cool is it like has a, a prom,
the sex prom every spring. Oh, you know, we should do,
we should all go together. Oh isn't it like it's your money. It's the, it's,
it's in June and it's on the first one. She of June. Alexis, you want to go?
I do want to go, let's go.
Which is where I come in. Test, test, test, test, test.
Right. Cause it ended up being that Robert and Alexis and I actually couldn't go
and then it was like, okay, then send the 10 the new guy.
Yeah. No,
I mean at the time it was like you were just milling around the office and you
look like maybe you need an adventure. So we were like, Hey,
do you want to go see these crabs? Like see the sex bro?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Business in front of me in the back.
So anyway, so I go, and then when I got there, it was still pretty early,
like maybe six, seven in the morning. It was a little bit rainy,
but when you walked down the beach, it was just littered in,
in probably thousands of horseshoe crap. This is what a horseshoe
grab down like
yeah, there's, there's kind of no way to hear it.
We just said we get a visual, like what does a horseshoe crab look like?
That's kind of like a family circle.
And then there's kind of like this French shielding part and then there's the
tail and a, um, I would call it a scuttling catcher's Mitt.
Yeah. Yeah. Not Bad.
So there were these hordes of Scott Catcher's Mitts, uh, you know,
scuttling around and uh, they, they actually move really slowly.
A lot of them had been knocked upside down by the waves and you could see their
soft underbelly. They have these 10 lobster like legs and,
and then walking around them were
Compton. Anyone want NYCLA called? It's funny phrase. Then a bunch of people
is stepping on a horseshoe crab. Was that one day.
Many of them were from a big pharmaceutical company,
which will make sense in a second.
But I'm glad my guide for this morning on the beach was a guy named Glenn.
Nice to meet you. Glen. Go very thin guy. Short hair, uh,
wearing socks and sandals. Yeah.
Um, and I'm the founder and director of the ecological research and development
group. And also, is it true, I thought,
I think I saw on your resume that you in the air force I was a,
was I was an air traffic
controller and a,
the first time I saw horseshoe crabs was in 1969 when I was stationed at Dover
Air Force Base,
which is right in your Bot being a young guy and cut it down to the beach
looking for something that might be going on. And I saw horseshoe crabs. Wow.
It wasn't until many years later that I kind of looped around into this thing,
but that was the first time I saw them
sort of saw some horseshoe crabs and kind of weirdly fell in love with them and
became really their like champion.
Oh, they're not all that attractive unless you've been around them a while.
I find them quite beautiful.
Glenn now leads these, you know, educational tours of horseshoe crabs,
especially at this time of the year. And he walked me up and down the beach, uh,
painstakingly explaining to me the rules of the, you know, of this x Prom.
The larger ones are females as a male.
At one point he pointed out two crabs that were stuck together.
So that guy that's attached to that female, yeah, that's his gal now
they were like locked to one another stuck upside down,
which makes it harder for them to write themselves. Like right now,
this surface rough enough where if they were separate,
there's a good chance it would flip them over and they'd be okay.
But because he's hanging in there,
the likelihood of that happening becomes more remote. But he'll die with her.
Like this is like a blockbuster Ronette here. This is like, yeah, I mean,
I don't, you know, you had to go back to remember Burt Lancaster on the beach.
You know,
I forget what movie that was where the waves are crashing over and that was
symbolic of the romance and they were both in Baden suits, you know,
embracing one another. Nobody.
So we, we've got a got a, an animal world version of that going on in the beach.
Right.
And Glenn's Romantic,
I just painted this sex orgy as a beautiful flowering,
like a mating season, like spring and nature. Kind of a beautiful thing.
Oh my God for that
realize really quickly was like what is it? Are those like Max?
Oh that's gross.
The reality of it was kind of more fun. Get a three.
There'd be like piles of crabs trying to have sex with each other. Yes,
exactly.
Trains have them all hooked together and they would be like going in the wrong
direction all the time. Like what is going on here?
You'd see like one crab in the middle, like a female, like a bigger one.
It's got this clause gripping and then three or four males like all trying to
mate with this one crowd at the same time.
And then when you look even closer nail, it turned out the female crab
was dead.
Roads
like this weird like necrophiliac foursome of crabs.
Uh, it was, it was, it was Kinda Raunchy actually.
Well my glasses
are getting all, uh, I'll talk to my,
but while I was standing watching all this, you know, hurly burly of crab sex,
I was struck by what I think is one of the central questions of this story
because it's almost impossible not to notice that I look like there's pieces.
Oh. And won them all. Yeah. But he's a lot,
a lot of these horseshoe crabs are really banged up.
Oh yeah. Goes right through. Like chunks of their shells are missing,
their eyes are missing.
You would think if someone had a hole in their head that size,
you're walking around big deal. But yeah, some of them,
they have holes that you could see their legs underneath that in the night and
they're all just fine. They just have all these kind of crazy,
what would seem to be fatal injuries,
but they're all just kind of walking around like it's no big deal.
Just consider it on the species level. So like,
like here's a creature that is lasted hundreds of millions of years.
It outlasted the dinosaurs and the asteroid that killed them,
it outlasted freezing oceans.
It's so far has survived the industrial age of humans.
And you look at it and you're like, how, what's it secret?
And it turns out that part of the answer to that has to do with that baby blue
blood. This is Alexis Madrigal again.
So our blood is red because hemoglobin is rich in iron, right?
And their blood is blue because it's rich in copper.
So their molecule that carries oxygen for them, it's called hemo Sinan.
But what's really interesting about this blood is this chemical system of
slowing down bacteria.
So say you're a horseshoe crab and in your blood there's a little bit of
bacteria maybe got through in a crack in your shell anyway,
in your blood. Are these cells called Amoeba site?
He's oval cells that are sort of on patrol in the bloodstream.
And when they encounter a particular kind of bacteria,
the Amoeba sites,
these oval cells excrete this substance called Coagula Gin,
which does exactly what it sounds like.
The area around where the intruders are. Just like Mu
[inaudible]
turns into this like jelly stuff,
that bacteria that snuck in and traps them like a grape trapped in a bowl of
Jello. Wow. And that crack in the shell, the Amoeba sites seal that off too.
And what does it do with the Gel then? Is it poop it out or something then?
Then it can actually attack the sails once they've been flowed down. Oh. So it,
it, it blobs the invader and then mobilize it.
And then some other uh, defense defenders come in and they can take it out,
take it out. And this super power fighting.
It's tiny battles in the bodies of these rather plain looking creatures.
You touch one of these guys before no first time. How does it feel?
Is the reason why people from pharmaceutical companies were on the beach that
day?
It's like you live your life and you have new idea with you.
This thing that's been playing out for literally millions of years. One day,
humans started to catch on to this
[inaudible]
and one human in particular morning. To explain.
We're going to leave the horseshoe crab just for a minute and talk a little bit
about injectable drugs that scientist and innovator, James Cooper,
any relation to James Fenimore Cooper of uh,
like the last of the Mohicans Guy Google, she's name is James Fenimore Cooper.
He was named after James Fenimore Cooper and his son is also named James
Fenimore Cooper. Wow. Um, but anyway, but anyway,
this James Fenimore Cooper told us that while it was a total miracle,
when injectable drugs like morphine came onto the scene,
it was also a bit of a nightmare because they didn't know about bacteria.
Occasionally the fluids they were injecting would become contaminated as soon as
they inject this materials that patients get infections and develop terrible
fevers or even die, that can be incredibly dangerous to us.
And so to make sure these drugs were free of bacteria that caused fevers,
they didn't just, you know, try it on a person and see if they died.
They checked it on a rabbit and they would have like,
like racks and racks of rabbits, like 24 rabbits in Iraq.
They are restrained by the neck rather loosely.
I mean like a pilgrim being punished in the town square. Exactly right.
And then they'd take a little sample of the thing they wanted to inject into a
person and then he would inject that into the rabbits year.
And if there's certain kinds of bacteria present, the rabbits will get a fever,
their temperature will go up.
And the way they measured their temperature was with these electric thermometers
up there. Bums. So if the rabbits temperature goes up,
we know we shouldn't put this drug inside a person,
but if there's no temperature spike,
this solution is safe to inject into Matt man or woman or children or really
anyone. So that's how crude it was. And it turns out this test,
it wasn't really that reliable either because rabbits are like pretty sensitive.
So even if sometimes they'll like see a new person and will get scared and then
they'll just have a fever because of that.
So it was really, it was not a great test, not great for us,
especially not great for the rapids.
After they would go through a few tests, sometimes even after only one,
they just, they kill them.
Um,
and to Rabbit Hall of Famer James Fenimore Cooper,
my joke is that I love to talk to rabbits because they're all ears, you know.
Anyway, back in the late sixties,
Cooper was a Grad student at Johns Hopkins University and one day one of his
professors came up to him in the, in the hall or wherever and kind of jokingly,
maybe somewhat seriously as Cooper, if you want to get out of this, uh,
institution with your degree,
you're going to need to find a way to pest for pirates is by something other
than the basically find a better way. That was sort of a joke,
although I think he met some of it lucky for Cooper. Around the same time,
this other professor at his university, Dr Levin,
had just come out with a paper on how horseshoe crab blood could theoretically
be used to test for bacteria in people
[inaudible]
and hearing Dr Levin present about it,
Dr. Cooper sat back in his chair and was like, wait a second. Oh,
what if we use the horseshoe crab blood to test our drugs?
Would it be possible then to take this test and adapted to test drug products
and we wouldn't have to kill all of those rapids.
So they got together, made the test work,
and as soon as we made that publication in 71 than the pharmaceutical industry
jumped right on it.
And so this particular chemical substance,
it's Coagula gin in the horseshoe crab blood actually became a major part of the
way that we test things that we're going to inject into our bodies.
And every hospital, as you walked down the, uh, the Carter, you look in a room,
there's an ivy bag hanging surgical instruments on a tray.
Injectables far pain infections, your dad's pacemaker, cancer,
chemotherapy, your grandma's new hit your kids Epi,
pen immunization shots.
All of these things have been tested with this material, this,
this test that we're able to do using this chemical that we extract from
horseshoe crabs,
this 450 million year old species.
Yeah. But in order to do all of that, in order to actually, you know,
keep our medicines safe,
they actually have to go out every year and,
and drain horseshoe crab blood seriously.
They have to keep doing this all every year. Yeah. They go out,
they get the crabs every year.
They drain their blood and then they go put them back out into the ocean.
It's like a like a, like a, like a horseshoe crab blood drive and the whole,
the whole, I mean it's,
there are a bunch of companies that do this and the whole industry is worth,
you know, like tens of millions of dollars.
Oh Wow. Really,
really wanted to see this all in action.
Like I wanted to go to one of these bleeding facilities after the break.
A lot diff and a very special guest will do just that.
They will infiltrate so to speak,
one of these bleeding facilities and witness the baby blue blood drive
firsthand. That's coming up.
This is Katie from Big Sky Montana.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, I'm Tracy and I'm a reporter here at radio lab.
I wanted to take a quick second to tell you about something that I think is
pretty cool that we make here at the show.
Besides the show we have a newsletter and I can already hear you say big deal.
Everybody has a newsletter but ours is really,
really good and worth your time and probably more worth your time than other
people's newsletters. So here it is.
First of all it lets you know when to release a new episode and secondly there's
this whole other section of our staff picks and that's just a list of things
that the Radiolab team have come across that were just really excited about.
And it could be something like, you know, Rachel Sake, our producer, you know,
she just worked on goon ads and she found out about this really cool frozen zoo.
And then there's our other producer Andy McCune, and she kinda tells,
told everybody to Google horse mustaches and it is definitely worth your time to
Google that. So go do that right now. Or it'll be me talking about,
you know, the joys are rewatching like my favorite TV show, living single.
So I hope you'll sign up. It takes about 30 seconds and it's free.
So go to radiolab.org back slash newsletter or you can text RL news as in a
Radiolab news two seven zero one zero one that's r l news two seven zero one
zero one and thanks.
But who is this personality who has gone so far as to imagine that narrator to
keep him company announcing the events of his life as if he were the star of
screen stage, all stolen card. You make me sound like such a freak.
Everyone should have a narrator thank you. Don't call in the air.
Step right in to the orbiting human circus of the air with Wny c studios,
special edition of orbiting human circus. Season one,
listen now, wherever you get your podcasts,
this is Radiolab.
We're back with lots of Nasser reporting on horseshoe crabs and the scientists
who love them, or at least love,
they're a very valuable blood and maybe them too, but mostly their blood.
And therein lies are up.
So they're basically like I think four or five companies that go out and find
horseshoe crabs and then extract their blood.
And I wanted to see like what does it look like?
So I sent out a few emails and then I was emailing these companies for like
three years and nobody ever returned my emails. I don't know why.
Maybe they didn't want bad press or I don't know,
maybe they weren't bleeding that year or whatever.
And so I'd basically given up on this story, but then this year,
these folks at one of the companies called Charles River laboratories and were
like, hey, why don't you just come down to Charleston south
and watch what we do here? So I went, you're just rolling. I'm rolling.
You're rolling. Let me double check. And along with me I brought yes, dust,
Dust Lulu. Hey, how's it going? Lulu Miller,
you guys shine the horseshoe crabs signal on the moon.
And I come around in a little.
Miller is a former radio lab staff or actually she is the first radio lab staff
member. Uh, besides myself and Robert and Ellen. And uh,
she is a cocreator of NPRs. Invisibilia we're, how did you get in on this?
I weirdly have had affection for these creatures my whole life.
I like grew up with them there. Some of my first memories.
What do you remember seeing? I remember seeing what I thought was a crab.
I was like probably three or four on the beach with my parents in Cape Cod where
we've gone my whole life. And,
and I just remember walking on the beach and seeing this like massive crab,
you know, a third of the size of my body basically.
And I remember kind of jumping back and my dad's saying, oh, take it up,
poke at it, you know, interact.
And so I kinda turned it over and I saw all those claws and I got scared and
then he, you know, he showed me it wasn't alive, it was a mold. Oh.
And he explained what a mold was,
that there had been a crab in there and it slid out and now was this perfectly
intact skin of what it used to be.
And you're wonder like, well where is it now and what's it doing now?
And do I ever leave a self behind? I don't know.
It was just little and I thought it was cool and we,
we brought it back to our porch.
I remember that it sat on our porch for years and like the dog would sniff at it
where
there's just ever since then there's just been a like mild poetic fascination
visitors report to build the building. See, I think that's, and Lulu,
did you have a feeling about this business of any sort before you've written
visited? Yeah, there's a part of me that wondered like,
Oh I totally love these creatures is this big bad company.
Just exploiting it for their blood. And you know,
I went with a little skepticism. Great, thanks. You know,
an eyebrow down and scrunch to the bleeding.
Fertility was just in this kind of under stated nondescript office park land.
There's like people in Capri pants and sandals basically from the outside it
looks like every other one story brick building.
Whew. But then when you go on the inside, suddenly you're hit with this.
Like I can smell it. Wash have a smell of crabs. Hey,
wow, that's now. How would you describe that smell? Kinda crab myth.
Yeah. It's a high ceiling,
brightly lit room with industrial things along one wall,
these shiny metal operating trays on wheels. So,
and no matter where we were standing, we just sort of managed to beat like,
exactly, oh, you need us out of the way. In a way,
be in your way though of all of these busy people rushing around a barn lab
coats, they're wearing hair nets, gloves on,
and they're pushing around these big gray bins on wheels. An inside.
Each bin
are the horseshoe crabs twist and turn in a little wave in their tail,
all heaped on top of each other, about 20 per Ben flex in their claws.
So, uh, we have our crabs coming in from our suppliers. That's Brad parish,
our guide. He explained to us that there are two parts to the blood donation.
We start by washing the animals, scrub the shell off the Barnum football.
They spray it, dunk it,
Lafayette and the it of which you speak are living animals. Yeah.
Like one at a time. These smooth shells are passed person to person,
rinsed and shining like Wonka land for crabs in here.
It's like a whole world. Yeah. In a way.
Here we're in the way, once they're washed the rack of one, two, three, four,
five, it's time for the bleeding. 16 crabs wheeled over going to go in,
crabs are taken out of their bins folded in half.
So their tails are kind of underneath and they're put on these racks where
they're strapped down with a bungee cord to hold them in place.
And then they're wheeled into this tent,
which is like a clean room zone that's like,
like got these sort of like plastic curtains all around.
Can we go, can we go in? We cannot go. Oh, we can't go in. Okay. Got It.
And they didn't let us go in there because as regular bacteria carrying humans,
we were far too dirty to enter this super, super clean room.
But we can peak right in. And when we did,
we saw that right at that fold in the crabs body
right at that hinge, there's like a little opening and the needle goes in
there and it was from that needle that this blood,
it's like brilliance. Yeah.
Kind of Saifai sky blue blood
slowly dripping into these things.
The glass bottle and the McRavs are kind of like, their little claws are going,
but they've just kind of looked like they're sitting there and they're draining
them of about a third of their blood.
What is your, uh, emotional sense of this scene?
Like it was kind of this, uh, feeling some sort of like,
what we're doing here is weird and
kind of
Vampirey. I don't know what it was like. We're sucking their blood.
So that's a little, it was a little creepy
like when, so lots of like,
I feel like when we were in there, hmm.
There's like so many, we were in the factory,
dozens and dozens of boxes filled each with like 10 huge crabs.
And we, we are in the, yeah, in that processing zone.
And before we went and saw the blood, this like may sound cheesy,
but it was actually profound and I keep thinking about it.
There was this moment,
okay, so here we go. Okay. What are we looking at?
Can I touch her when one of the guys in the factory, Oh,
you're sure he can had pulled out from these bins.
This big female horseshoe crab. Okay. Oh yeah, yeah,
yeah, I do. And he's just sort of holding her by the shell. Hi. Whoa.
The tail is really coming right at me here. Yeah.
So little herd of the claws are going up and her tails kind of waving around.
Right. So there's a lot of uh, yeah. Club activity. Exactly.
And so we'll take these calls and he like turned her over so she's upside down.
And then he took his hand and just let her claws kind of grab his hand.
And so that there's sort of pinching my hands here, but it doesn't hurt.
There's not much power to them.
They're just using that to sort of grab the food and I try and get into their
mouth that I get a little pin. Okay. Yup.
And so I just kinda slowly stuck my hand out toward her claws.
Oh. And her closet like engulfed my hand. Oh, here. Oh,
they're very quiet. They're very, very clasby.
It wasn't a scrabbly kind of like foreign,
a touch,
the all the clause clasped in unison really tight actually cut it out.
It's kind of a massage. So I am being like,
this horseshoe crab is holding my head. Wow.
To me. And of course this is just silly project.
Dang. So I'm saying that, but like it felt like,
I know it wasn't, but it felt like a communication. Like,
I'm in this Bin and these people are doing weird things and I want to be back in
the sea and I'm upside down and I'm about to go into like have a sink, you know,
one of those like shower heads,
spray it all up in my under sides and then I'm going to be Bungee corded and
drained. Like it was almost, it wasn't like it was in pain,
but I had this almost like primal creature to creature help me.
Yeah. Like, I mean, part of me felt that too. Uh,
but I mean on the other hand, like they, they do get to go home
towards,
so the same fishermen that bring the crabs to us are then going to deliver them
back to the ocean and release them. They're set free,
straight back to the water.
And how many crabs do they do this to? Every year? About 500,000.
A horseshoe crabs every year kept bled.
Do the crabs that get bled and then released, I mean,
did they just say swim away? Fine or today?
So some of them do die after the bleeding. There's this a,
a small percentage,
like I think the conservative estimate is around like 10%. Um,
but that might be a high estimate or it might be a low S. I have no idea.
I think it's 15, 15%. Okay. So let's say like 15%.
So if you're talking about 500,000 crabs being bled every year,
that that,
that means about 75,000 horseshoe crabs are dying because of bleeding every
year. Eh, you know, they actually,
in that original paper that I looked at again, Alexis Madrigal,
they were actually able to see that a lot of the,
the crabs don't have like bled crabs and non bled crabs,
like have slightly different movement. Um, and that's because, you know,
maybe one of them is missing 30% of its blood, but they needed to,
they needed to double check on that.
And so they did see that the [inaudible] animals appear more lethargic,
they move, you know, uh, more slowly and like imagine if,
imagine if you had to go like harvest deer and then bleed them of 30% of their
blood and then you'd like leave them back out in the forest.
Like there's something about that. That seems so bizarre.
It seems very medieval.
Is there any hope of getting out of this whole vampire relationship we have with
the horseshoe crabs? Well perhaps,
and let me tell you a brief story about a bird smallish bird cinnamon in color
with a long bill. It's called a red non. Yup.
The incredible thing about red knots is of all the birds in the world,
the red knot makes it one of the longest migrations,
nearly 10,000 miles to go from the very southern tip of South America all the
way up to northern northern Canada up into the Arctic circle where they lay
their eggs and the whole journey takes about five months.
And what happens is thousands of these red not birds will take off from South
America.
They'll fly like 4,000 miles north up to Brazil and they'll stop them for just
like a couple days rest up, eat some food,
and then the thousands of them take this guys again.
And they fly up along the eastern coast of South America,
over the Atlantic Ocean. But before they get to their final resting grounds,
they make one more stop. One pivotal, crucial rest up in
the Delaware Bay. Yeah. Dried up.
Now when I was in Delaware, there weren't like a ton of birds terror.
But basically these birds, when they make this journey,
they rely on horseshoe crabs because I don't know if you've been noticing all
the eggs they need to eat millions of horseshoe crab eggs to complete their
migration. Oh, this is an egg cluster right there. Oh Wow. Oh Wow.
Oh wait. Really careful where I sat down and this is the thing.
It's weirdly these birds that might actually free the horseshoe
crabs from us. Yeah. Yep. And to explain, I got in touch with this guy.
Uh, my name is Jay Bolden, a biologist in the global quality laboratory.
Is that Eli Lilly and company. So Eli Lilly and company,
it's this huge pharmaceutical companies that makes you know,
cancer drugs and antidepressants, a lot of insulin and things like that.
And real quick
people are at the core of our commitment to manufacturing.
Here's a message from an executive, I'm the driving force behind our innovation.
Radiolab is brought to you by anyway. Um,
one of the things that company has been helping innovate is horseshoe crab
blood, a synthetic version of horseshoe crab line. Yeah. So, and you know,
Jay explained to me,
if you kinda like zoom out for a second and think about what it means to use
horseshoe crab blood for this, you know, vital thing in medicine.
The problem is there needs to be a supply of horseshoe crabs and you know,
global warming,
global climate change is real rising sea levels and habitat loss.
I could have some supply chain consequences, which isn't good. No.
And so it was actually all the way back in 1997 some researchers out of the
University of Singapore cloned this, the factor see protein,
the essential factor. See Protein in horseshoe crab blood that goes
blue, blue, blue, blue, blue, blue
around the bad bacteria.
And now we can make the protein of interest instead of getting that directly
from horseshoe crabs. Huh. So why aren't we already using that? Yeah,
so the problem,
well Jay explained that there's a whole bunch of different reasons,
but one of the big ones,
it was that you already had an industry built on horseshoe crab blood.
And so there was no real immediate incentive to change,
which is actually how we get back to,
yeah, tell me. Good friends. The birds.
So turns out people like these birds a lot,
like actually way more than horseshoe crabs,
but since the birds eat the horseshoe crab eggs,
their feet is kind of entwined. So like if the horseshoe crab is not doing well,
then the bird's not going to do well. And so Jay figured,
why don't I just go around to all the bird conservationists?
They use some of their political power and contacts and it's only now that we're
starting to come upon
a new dawn
[inaudible]
good afternoon everyone and
welcome here. This is a great place to be. Today
in May of 2018 Jay was standing on a stage along with some conservationists to
announce that Eli Lilly would be one of the first companies to use synthetic
horseshoe crab blood.
The big headline news here is that the pharmaceutical industry can actually
replace probably up to 90% of the use of horseshoe crab blood without incurring
any major regulatory change
[inaudible],
which means these horseshoe crabs can finally be freed up their servitude and
bondage to mankind and get back to doing, you've got a three song.
What is going on here? What they love
[inaudible]
Whoa, but here's the weird thing.
I think like if the synthetic comes through and we get it perfect and it works
and we never have to drain another horseshoe crab,
then they just become these weird kind of sea spiders again and that that could
be a really bad thing for them. Yeah, exactly.
This is actually something that Alexis Madrigal all talks about too,
because most of the other things that these horseshoe crabs have ever been used
for it and the history of their encounter with humans,
that has resulted in the death of like large numbers of them because before we
ever valued them for their blood, we basically did two things with them. Thing.
One, we turned them into a fertilizer. We would catch them,
boil and grind them and then just stick them in the soil as a way of promoting
plant growth or thing too. We'd catch them,
cut them up and use them to like a,
as bait to catch a more valuable species,
like a particular kinds of snails. Okay. So I have right here in front of me,
this comes from the Atlantic states marine fisheries commission,
which their numbers say that, you know,
as of the late nineties there were nearly 3 million horseshoe crabs being killed
every year for commercial fishing. 3 million. Wow.
But more recently we put restrictions on how many horseshoe crabs can be used
for commercial fishing, for Bait. Um, it's even like in a lot of states,
it's a crime to go to a beach and just take a, uh, you know,
a bunch of horseshoe crabs. Like in New Jersey, if you take a horseshoe crab,
you could get fined $10,000.
The thing that I've always wanted to keep in mind with this is like if you're
gonna have to be, you know, hooked up to some economic system,
which most animals in our world are,
you kind of want to be hooked up to one that's super high value and that doesn't
kill you.
And so the fear is if like,
if the synthetic works and we no longer need horseshoe crabs for their precious
blood, then we just go back to chopping them up,
putting them in the ground and using them for bait
because they live where we live.
They live along our most populous shore and they're right there for the taking.
You know, they're not prepared for our murderer samples.
Hi, I'm [inaudible] nice to meet you. Nice to meet. Thanks for having us here.
Yeah, I'm more than glad to,
and there was this moment where everything just kind of flipped for me,
you know,
like where I realized that as cruel and kind of Grizzly as the draining of the
blood themes that actually may be the best thing for these creatures.
Like our selfishness maybe protecting them.
Oh, you want to see some more horseshoe crabs. Yes, yes, yes.
So this is our very last stop on our trip down to South Carolina and we met this
fisherman named Jerry Gulp who is employed. Yeah,
to collect the horseshoe crabs for the company. What a peaceful little spot.
So we were in this forest. Yeah, I know.
This feels like the most secluded place.
Nowhere with Jerry walking around this little pond.
I wore the exactly wrong shoes. I just scored the wrong thing.
What's known as a holding pond where they put the crabs before they go off to
the facility. And while we were down there, when he got there,
Jerry likes scooped some water out of the pond. That's just a bottle of water.
But then he held the bottle up to our faces, seeing the babies were there.
Oh, all of those. Every, oh wow. There's so many of them. How many of,
yeah, they do 'em a hundred thousand eggs at a season.
Wow.
They're like the size of like a really round grain of rice or like pro cous.
Cous cous like are
they, were they laying the eggs here or, or, or did you get the eggs from the,
where you lay their eggs along the shore? Oh,
literally right here. Oh Wow.
I feel like we heard a tiny bit about, but what, what's the,
what's the story of how you went from,
or your family went from being kind of seafood, uh, you know,
fishermen to doing this kind of crazy different thing? Well,
we're just a bunch of fishermen and add, but Jerry told us, uh,
the gist of it is back when his dad was doing seafood fishing, you know,
it was just a tight,
then it was in this seventies his dad was catching a lot of horseshoe crabs,
selling them off for bait.
And then one day this guy just showed up at his house suit and tie,
told him my dad did. If he would quit selling them for Bait, you know,
he'd make a deal for him. He would buy him, buy him for more money.
So Jerry's dad said, sure, we've been doing it ever since. And,
and I got something I want you guys to know as a fisherman,
I'm proud to be part of it. I find it to be,
I want to say it's the most noble thing I do because I get to touch every one of
you guys because it's used for making sure medication is safe for us and
can't say that about soft shell crabs or, or guru grouper,
you know, you touch everyone and then you touch it again and return it. Well,
I touched you indirectly. Indirectly.
I'm touching all of us here because we're all part of it.
So it's pretty neat thing.
If you had to describe your feelings for the crabs, for the horseshoe crabs,
uh, how do you feel about them? Well,
I have a lot of respect for him and
I almost feel like it's, um, divine design.
Nowhere she crab is, you know, I've seen him fishing for them,
you know,
they're nuisance then and now I see him on this side where they're important to
human society. And, um,
I just draws me back to the idea that is was divine design.
They've been around for 400 million years. It took them,
this took us this long to figure it out, I guess.
Out of curiosity, where did that, where did that leave the two of you? Well,
well for me, I mean, Jerry the fisherman, he's, he's totally right. Like we,
we just figured this out.
These crabs of being Clark canting us this whole time.
They have this hard one superpower that they've probably had since, you know,
before like three branches on our evolutionary tree. And,
and, and in evolutionary terms, like, like they're the winners. We're the,
we're, we're chumps, we're, we're baby chumps.
There's this like there something
miraculous inside them. And, and in a certain way,
it's easy to stand next to them and feel almost small like that.
We're not unlike an asteroid or just another thing,
they're probably going to endure like we are a blip to them and yet
where a dangerous blip and and in a weird way like people,
the people we met down here, the people doing this work,
this blood harvesting work in a way came to represent the best way to treat the
crabs. Exactly. Treating them like gangs.
There are these rules in place to make sure that the horseshoe crabs are only
picked up by hand and you can't pick them up by the tail
cause you can injure the muscle in the tail.
We keep them covered when we transport them,
like they're also on a time clock.
We've got to get them back as quick as possible.
They have to be back to the ocean within 24 hours. When they get to the lab,
we give it a manicure, pedicure.
Each one gets scrubbed clean by hand
and then they borrow some blood from it and bring it back and let it go.
And he showed us how he returns them to the water and he like,
he built this fricking water slide slide to get down to do it more gently.
No, now we pick them up, set them into this slide in the water,
takes them to the river before we used to pick them up and toss them. Yeah,
I mean we've gotten away from tossing him. It's amazing.
I've got a slide on my dog,
200 foot long water slide where the rehydrate on their way to the river.
[inaudible]
see how fair stake holders
do you want to get your finger gun in here? They squeezer want to hold it?
Yeah, so this is the male, that's the male.
Okay. Females, at least we just interrupted his embrace game.
It's cuddling. It's continent
[inaudible].
This piece was reported by lots of Nasser with help from Damiano Marchetti and
was produced by Annie Mcewen and Matt Kielty with help from Liza Yeager.
Thanks to Lakia with ambition.
Everyone at Lonza is global endotoxins testing summit,
Mike Kendrick and Brad Floyd of the South Carolina Department of Natural
Resources, also Tamara and Ho at Eli Lilly. And of course cake from tress.
John Dubcek and the rest of the team at Charles River. I'm Chad Ab. I'm Ron.
I'm Robert Krulwich. Thanks for listening to plays in this. He compressed
sort of message. Hey, it's Alexis Madrigal. Hey,
this is Lulu calling you from a foggy area. That was my voice on the machine.
I had no idea that was still there.
Radiolab was created by Jad rod and it's produced by Soren Wheeler gearing.
Keith is our director of sound design. Rhea matricide.
Pedea is our managing director. I staff includes Simon Adler,
Becca wrestler Rachel Cusick, David Gavel. [inaudible] Tracy Hun,
who is hell fun on Twitter, not jokey. Robert Krulwich. Any McKeown,
lots of Nasser.
Melissa O'Donnell or any black Pat Walter and Emmalie the web web web there you
help from Cima Levi. He met Ole. Yeah, FEMA.
That sugar is Michelle Harris. You would think I could,
could've done that better.
I've been working in radio for a decade and a half right by and this message,
well known.
[inaudible] known to made it from Lulu. Below.
Yeah.
Hello? Hello.
They go in a pretty good, um,
hang up the phone. You should still be there. Hi. Beautiful.
Um, so, uh,
word on the street is you have a story to read.
I do. I do have a story. I think my levels are okay.
Um, I have a really weird horseshoe crab deep dive.
So you have to pretend you have to like really channel me speaking like a kind
of Jersey Dude.
Like I picture that this voice is a good a jersey kind of Tony Soprano voice to
try to imitate it. Okay. But like go there in your I will,
I will be translating into that voice in my head. Okay. Okay.
Alright. So it's called me and Jane
[inaudible].
There is nothing finer than the feel of Jane suckling algae from my back.
If that sounds gross, just imagine how it would feel for a moment.
A fine horseshoe crab like Jane climbing up onto your shell,
nibbling and scraping around to remove this past week's failures and setbacks
and scabs.
A glittering cascade of unsexy cunning all over your shell. Flip sees,
she'd say when her work was complete. My turn. Sorry,
I'm a short of breath. This is a pregnancy curse, but I'll just,
there might be some breaths you're going to have to take out or even notice
sounded great. Okay, good.
Flip sees she'd stay when her work was complete my turn and I'd climb back up
under her back two around a bit. Pop, a few barnacles off,
but I never really did that great of a job for two reasons. One,
I am a bit lazy too.
After years of being a bit lazy and allowing my Jane's Shell to become encrusted
and salt scabs, algae, barnacles, and more than a few muscles,
I've come to find it all quite beautiful.
The whole stinking mess is a topographical record of our history.
When I say this to Jane, she rolls all nine of her eyes, but I mean it.
That patch of black LG on her up,
the Malick Rouge that appeared the night last spring when we spawned under a new
moon, which is of course no moon at all.
That white gunk near her tail from a nap in the mud,
the actual remnant of a cuddle or those barnacles on her backside.
I know the very day they latched on,
it was on our trip up to Maine to see the tide pools.
Jane had been scared of going scared of black bears are humans are Yada, Yada,
Yada. I cut in and told her.
Those were just myths perpetuated by fearful crabs with too much goddamn time on
their hands. Life is for living.
I told her as I thrust her into the Gulf stream and boy what a time we had.
We soaked in tide pools. We lay out in the sun.
Jane picking away at my back while I walked her through my idea for a starfish
novel. The barnacles must have suction onto her somewhere between the boyhood
stargazing scene, spooky starfish, star resonance,
and the seagull attack scene.
Even if I hadn't been too exhausted from my fit of inspiration to work on her
barnacles that night,
I doubt I would have been able to pry them off as they proved the next morning
under that glaring Maine Sun. They were as hard as rock. Oh, well.
Without these spots, I fear I'd forget that life would become a wash.
I whisper these kinds of things to Jane when she seems a shame of her little
green beard or when she sluggish from her kelp tails pulling in the tide.
The Steans and scabs are the particulars of our experience.
I tell her they are our memories made physical or record forged in desiccating
cease stink of our love. I mean,
it's not that I don't appreciate a smoother shell.
When I see one Jefferson's wife for example,
it is hard not to notice her swimming by her shell turgid with the strain of
perfection and if you happen to be onshore when she comes up for air watch out,
it is almost like an optical illusion. Water on water,
a hump of liquid emerging from itself.
What I'd give to reach out with the tiny hairs in my most private of spots,
my NAFO basis and run them along her shell. Oh,
but still you couldn't pay me to trade places with Jefferson while I'm off on a
fish.
Kark has bender with the guys or having a quiet morning to myself going Mollis
contin.
Jefferson is at home in that same damn ditch tending to his wife all day long.
He picks and buffs and scrapes and scrubs washing away her every residue.
She won't even tolerate a bit of salt buildup.
It was a simpler existence with my Jane, my old barnacled Gal.
More free. Lately though, I have to admit,
I've been feeling restless. We're not fighting at all.
We're still very much able to make each other laugh,
but I feel as though big things within me are becoming uneasy.
I mentioned something along the lines of this to Jane about a week ago,
but she assured me it was nothing, just physical time to Molt,
but the moon proved her wrong.
The brightening moon and the descent of thousands of new horseshoe crabs on the
cove. It's the spawn. Of course,
the upcoming spawn must be what's triggering this uneasiness in my gut because
while the first part is lovely,
there is nothing like the feel of your pet pops out in the ocean holding onto
the edge of Jane's Shell with your grippers,
10,000 other crabs clacking so hard around you.
It's sometimes induces a sea steam.
What happens afterwards is unsettling.
Something strange comes over everybody.
Jefferson is no longer high strung. Jefferson, his wife,
no longer a prima Donna Frank who's always been kind of weird and lonely,
seems okay.
Everybody is lifted from theirselves or rather ourselves seem to lift from our
bodies and leave us.
We become one without our peculiarities at giant 10,000 [inaudible].
As we fall asleep that night,
thousands of us sinking into the coal mud all at once.
A kind of communal dream takes place and we awake United.
We share food, take turns guarding the eggs,
drop our suspicions of one another.
We are an efficient machine of a species without the drag of the individual.
I think there could be a book in this,
a sort of anti hard Dinny and treatise the promise of the Commons.
Imagine a completely selfless species. What good we could do,
how quickly we could rise, but alas,
curse of us creatures unable to change a thing about ourselves.
Since the dinosaurs,
we can never get this elevated state to last any longer than a couple of weeks.
It ends instantaneously with the hatch.
Once we've watched as tiny versions of US smaller than clams with little button
tales disappear into the surf,
the collective conscious begins to decay ourselves,
float back down into our shells and we feel that familiar itch again of
loneliness, a self confined irrevocably to its own body.
That's when we become assholes again and dickheads and self serious
know-it-alls. And so my hunch,
I tell Jane is that this strange gurgling in my gut is some kind of quantum
vertigo. Yeah, that's it. Quantum Vertigo,
myself longing to be set free into the ether where it can leap and spin and do
whatever it is selves do up there and dastardly old me.
This collection of hard shell and Claus desperate to keep it inside.
But no, Jane was right.
It was just time to molt. Huh?
She said after she heard the telltale rumble from underneath my prison, Oma,
poor old crab thinking he's the next political theorist stirring with ideas when
really it was just a case of skeletal indigestion. I whipped her with my tail,
shut up. She was about to respond,
but a clattery burp came out instead. Huh?
I said mutual mutual. Molting Jane side,
splendid. As we readied ourselves for the process.
There's not much you can do, but stand there and take it. I realized something.
What timing. I said to Jane,
we'll have fresh bodies just in time for the spawn pristine shells.
I thought you liked my encrustations, said Jane staring out at the sea.
I do. I gulped my darling. Of course I do.
It was right around then that she started to split.
Her head started craning forward and I watched nauseated and thrilled as a
bigger wetter version of her began sliding out.
It took hours, this arduous process of slipping out of yourself,
but when she finally emerged, she was a sight to behold like Jane,
but gleaming and massive. I better go. She said,
I know I whispered.
The soft and jelly like knew Jane would need to find a secluded place to hide as
her shell hardened, shall I find you in our spot. Sure.
She said and began to slowly, carefully step away.
I laid down next to her old body in the sand.
It was almost like laying with her any old day that trustee silence of her
listening, but with her shell completely empty. Now,
that familiar pattern of barnacles took on a frightening weight.
Something about them made me feel very worried, but I couldn't tell you what.
Eventually I two found my shell splitting. It wasn't the easiest of molts.
I'll spare you the gory details,
but let's just say the old meat didn't want to let the new me through and it
made its reluctance known with a deep gash down my back.
But at last I emerged bloodied and gelatinous.
I limped to some bushes nearby there. I waited as my back began to harden
through the brambles.
I had a good view of our old shells lying side by side in the sand.
Two little humps in front of the sea.
I gave that us for hours as the moon slid across the sky.
There was me, the old me,
a shiny little dome reflecting the Moon's journey in miniature and there was
Jane, the old Jane, a body,
so carpeted and weeds and stone that she reflected only us.
I awakened to legs, human ones, swishing by my brambles.
The rubber pads on its feet make horrible squeaking noises. I get low,
the legs halt for a moment and then run over to the old Jane and the old me,
the creature,
a little one for a human yanks old me by the tail and brings me up to his head.
I watch as it studies my private underside then turns me over and places me back
down. Thank God right where I had been in the sand.
It runs its strange hand along my smooth shell.
It turns to examine old Jane, her sweet fas, her barnacles,
our life, her shell cracks under the rubber pad of its foot.
Cracks into a thousand pieces.
Little bastard dares to pick old me up again and all I can do is watch from my
brambles as it runs away with me as it runs away with my past self dragging it
ruthlessly down the shore.
The spine has come and gone. I looked everywhere for Jane,
waiting by our spot, calling her name into the clacking shells, nothing.
Now I spend most evenings underwater with frank. Weird.
Frank awaiting her return.
The fish won't stop nibbling at my molting wound.
I can feel flatworms burrowing into my back.
I ask frank to help me clean it,
but he spits muscles and tells me I've got to be kidding.
My Shell is growing itchy with grit.
I don't know if it's sand or barnacles or what.
This afternoon I simply stood before the undertow and called her name and to its
haunting screams,
Jane Jay
[inaudible].
Frank tells me to shut up about my starfish novel.
Everyone does a coming of age starfish novel. He says, I mean,
write the damn thing. If you want, just please stop talking about it.
As I sit with him, LG sprouting on my lip,
I rethink the value of a self screw. The promise of the collective.
I think sometimes one self can be a pretty good thing. The self,
like a gene for instance.
I keep getting hit with shards of grit that instead of bouncing off my shell,
now get cut in my kelp tangles. I feel sluggish,
unwieldy in constant pain.
I think on past selves that smooth old me.
What is a self anyway? What endures with the soul.
A thing of question and my body now long gone. I said,
even continuous.
I have the distinct sense though. Jane would tell me,
this is magical thinking that the old me is off somewhere on the mainland near
that little human creature.
I can picture that clean old shell of drying out near some flower pots being
occasionally sniffed up by an idiotic canine with a sloppy tongue. Yes,
I'm sure of it though. Jane would scrunch up all nine of her eyes and say,
of course you're sure of it. You're making it up.
The old me is preserved in pristine form on the mainland while the smashed
shards of my sweet old Jane and crusted in the very stuff of our love
disintegrate into the sea.
Perhaps it's little bits of her that are sticking to me now.
There's my horseshoe crabs. Oh, that's great. That's really nice.
Yeah, it was really nice to listen to while lying on the floor here. Oh, good.
I'm glad. That's lovely.
Um, I, I didn't, I had no idea.
You had such an affection for horseshoe crabs before all this began where the
story began. The holding hand,
the holding hands scene makes a lot a lot of sense. I mean,
it makes sense in the moment listening to, yeah. But even with this context,
it makes more sense now.